[Applaudissements]
ces canaux http j'amène ce dossier il ya
des petits papiers avec des imitations
de dante
elle fait un petit cocon d'imitation je
vais démarrer avec géraldine nakache à
moins que vous ayez limitation préféré
je crois vous faites bien le petit
suisse exactement à les y attend quoi
sur quoi françois hollande ou non c'est
pas parce qu'il fallait pas le dire mais
non mais
[Applaudissements]
selma pour eux c'est de ma faute je le
dis faut faire deviner d'accord allez on
vous donne je suis là je sais pas ce que
c'est et un animateur de koh lanta
tu peux me lever et tout est à l'aise il
venait alors allez y regarder sur cette
caméra peut être parce qu'on n'a jamais
parlé dans tout ce qui est dedans non
mais t'as fait une démarche et où les
marges dans une démarche se fait une
imitation doit à eau
[Applaudissements]